since Glee you played Hedwig I did on
Broadway yes and that is a massive
transformation for any man to make yes a
huge transformation I think we have a
picture of you as Hedwig and yeah you
know what you do look I have to say you
look good I I think I look it's
something that I took away from that
show when you're when you're a woman for
the better half of a year you start to
realize that well all we have is this is
it this is it we worry about our hair
and that's and whatever we wear make it
worry about that's it yeah you've
nothing to worry about so taking play
yeah being walking around and in heels
and makeup I just go god I've never
looked this good in my life it's all
downhill once I take the makeup off
that's yeah so my my absolute respect
and admiration of the ladies of Iraq and
that war paint for the better half of
most of occasionally when you're in
comedy occasionally you have to put on
high heels for a comedy sketch over the
years what's comedy sketch are you
talking about at home the privacy of my
own home no but I Andy you've worn heels
it's impossible yeah I don't see it it's
like it's you do it for a comedy bit and
you think you're gonna break your ankle
almost instantly yeah and the ladies do
it almost like gobby look at those what
do we got it check these bad boys yeah
she's no problem at all I would not have
guessed that those were boys it's
amazing I think walking around in heels
is such a humbling experience for men
because you not only do you realize how
how when we do this all the time but
there's sort of like a there's a power
to it and it's very it's an empowering
feeling of just this sort of sexual
energy that drives see it may be because
Hedwig is also very sexual creature
right but it was an amazing experience
I immediately empathize with every girl
I've ever dated sort of a girlfriend now
is like now you know
you